Hi and welcome to Descriptive Statistics. Whether you're
a financial advisor, sports coach, or the everyday person,
statistics allows you to summarize data and shapes how
we make decisions. In the first half of our
statistics series, you will learn how to compute
values from data by hand, and by using Google
spreadsheets. By the end of this course, you'll have
the tools necessary to gather, organize, compute and visualize
information from a data-set. And for the final project, you'll
use the tools you have learned to compute statistics hidden within
a deck of cards. So I'll let Katie Corminick take
over from here so you can get started with the class.